david how can democrats better appeal to
rural voters
so i don't know if this will be seen as
controversial
by people in my audience but
a lot of democratic rhetoric on gun
control
is completely counterproductive i am
probably right there with
95 of the policy
that many democratic lawmakers want on
gun safety
but every time that democrats uh
campaign on gun control
number one many sound very uninformed
very very uninformed it's like do they
do they even understand how guns work
and that's a real problem for a huge
part of this country including rural
folks who remember
rural folks relationship to guns is very
different than that of people who live
in cities and suburbs and and other
places
number two i think that
the focus needs to better emphasize
economic issues in a way that relates to
working class maybe better
than sort of like uh tech millennials
and i think that
sometimes the economic rhetoric of
democrats
works pretty well for young people and
people working in white-collar jobs but
who are just not paid that well
or with a lot of student debt but often
is not rhetoric and language
that's well tuned to more rural folks
and this includes farmers this includes
factory workers and and
you know just every once in a while
talking about unions
there's lots of rural folks who have one
local employer where you drive 40 miles
to a factory where we might
think being on the left they should love
to hear about how we support
unionization
look at what happened in alabama with
amazon where they voted against
unionizing now of course there was a
huge propaganda war and it's a much more
complicated thing
but having spoken to people who work in
factories
in the midwest and in other places just
talking about unions is not going to do
it for democrats so i think that it's
sort of a three-pronged approach
i think the rhetoric around gun control
around elections
has to be either dropped or fixed it
doesn't mean you stop working on the
issues it just means you you stop
campaigning so aggressively on that
because it turns a lot of those rural
folks off number two
you figure out how to better talk to
farmers and agricultural
employers and workers and number three
you tweak the economic message to
not be so union heavy but more about
understanding
the plight of a lot of these
economically ravaged areas
where whether the one employer is
unionized or not and i support the
unionization
that's not a path to fixing or dealing
with
the way that the area has been ravaged
big picture
overwhelmingly by the republican sort of
supply side policies that came out of
the 1980s those would be my three kind
of bits of advice
for democrats to better appeal to rural
voters and the truth is that appealing
to rural voters
in california versus mississippi
are certainly two different things and
and the midwest as a third one
those are my initial thoughts let me
know what you think we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com see you then one of
our sponsors is privacy.com they're
giving you five dollars when you sign up
for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air
it'll even auto fill the card number
with one click and the payment
is taken out of your checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com
slash pacman